[Music]
so they're all like starting with sub
um and it just means substitution that's
what it means i tried to find something
short i didn't work obviously right
something longer than that
so it makes sense instead of missing so
we're going to substitute missing values
for something else
and uh the setup is
you know we use that with the data data
here just means like the gt table data
so you always start with gt
and then um you use this function and
that's data
and columns uh basically you can focus
this function over any columns you want
but by default it's everything so it'll
just go through every single column
and
no big deal if like there's no missing
values in those columns it'll just you
know skip over those
so it's kind of nice you can just like
almost like it's almost like paint by
numbers or
i'm trying to find the right analogy but
i can't seem to do that
it'll just find things which apply and
if they don't apply
no big deal
and you can even run it if you don't
have missing values at all
it'll still work
no change but you can feel safe doing
that in case you have some like table
inputs that may or may not have missing
values you don't know that ahead of time
so that's kind of cool they can do that
um so let me show you this we have a
built-in data in gt
it's a little hard to fit although the
idea is that it does fit it's only apros
and a small table it's just for like
messing around with tables and gt so i'm
gonna make this even smaller uh
there will be a few columns get rid of
row and group
and then put down the gt with this gt
function
so if you know nothing about gt this is
how you first started
uh and right away we can use submissing
so in this case we can use column names
but for this one i'm just using like
indices so one and two are numb and char
and four to seven are the rest of the
columns here
uh and we're going to place in columns
one two we have any values there's one
here and one there we're gonna replace
any's with the text missing
and uh just to be a bit different in
columns four to seven
we'll replace the nas with nothing
two ways of saying
it's missing i don't know
uh so you can totally do that it's great
uh so i'm gonna run this and immediately
you'll see the effect missing missing
and a whole lot of nothing here in these
columns
so kind of cool um
by default i'm just going to change
things here a bit i'm going to take out
this missing text it's not the default
value
so if i do this and run it again
the default is an m dash and it's hard
to sort of like write that to represent
what an m dash is
here that default in gt is three dashes
it magically takes that and converts
into an m dash because there's no way in
markdown to say i want m-dash you just
can't do it this actually becomes like
uh like
a horizontal rule which is not what you
want in a cell probably
maybe you do but i don't think you do uh
so
with that
said
you can even use two to get like a
smaller dash that in this case that's an
end dash
and
maybe you can see it maybe you can it's
a slightly smaller dash and of course
you can go back to this which is a
hyphen so
there you go so the dash becomes smaller
and smaller with less of these hyphens
used
so yeah so that's
submissing
and this is actually nothing really new
um
we used to have this function it used to
be called front missing it's just been
renamed to sub missing because i want to
move things into a separate family and
have a bunch of other functions which do
the same sort of thing
um you can still use the former but it
gives a warning which you may not want
to see every each and every single time
you want to make a table
so just you know migrate your remind
missings over to submissing if you have
some code that
you're just gonna run the future
let's find out
it does yeah uh you have to wrap it with
nd
and uh so let's actually do this let's
do um
just go on like not there so this is a
okay do bold just so you can really see
it
um
so i'm gonna run this
yes it does take mark down which is
great um
easy way to make you have to style it
you know after the fat we need to use
that so let's do emo so let's put inside
this md thing
i'm pretty sure that is super important
because that just becomes
like html
it worked
it really worked okay that's great
this is fun i love like you know i
didn't know for sure that would work
will work without md probably not right
but i don't know let's give it a roll
let's see
whoa oh yeah yeah it just gives you a
different flavor you don't need that md
okay that's cool that's cool
that is very
[Music]
cool so here's some really new stuff
like it's new both in like
like twilight it's like it's a 0.6
sub-zero
full function you can either think of
like a blue ninja or a refrigerator it's
totally up to your imagination what that
might invoke in your mind but basically
what it really is is if you give it a
zero value like it's truly zero not
rounded to zero but like really zero
then you can replace that zero with
something and it might be kind of fun to
do that who knows
um
let's just find out okay so basically
the same idea as sub missing instead of
missing text it's
zero text and the default is nil i don't
know why i chose that i think i saw it
somewhere and i thought that's kind of
cool you never see that i'm gonna put
that in instead of just you know using
this that seemed kind of like too boring
for me because just replacing the thing
you have but the same thing
okay for this i'm gonna actually make a
new table using the table function from
dplyr and the table
package i can make a small table which
has
a bunch of values but also some zeros
and these are like perfect zeros it's
not zero point zero zero zero or
whatever they're just like zeros okay so
with this table the zero values will be
given replacement text okay and in this
case this is kind of cool right because
you can like just use this without
anything
and the default will just work i mean
you may not like the default value but
uh you know it's pretty easy to use you
have to admit okay
uh so let's try that
let's run this and see if it works
it totally works okay that's awesome and
the cool thing is like if you use from a
format number on the same column
this will still work like it won't like
cancel out things like other parameters
do that's kind of like a different thing
with these sub functions
you can run it with
within the same columns as the
formatters
and it won't interfere it won't do
anything weird it won't cancel out the
formatting
it's kind of nice okay so let's try it
with a different zero text uh again
markdown will totally work
like
zero
should totally work
yeah that's great
um
i wonder if there's a movie let's give
it a shot just if only to like check our
knowledge of this package
yeah
um yeah sub zero
really simple
it's meant to be simple
why would you use that um
i don't know i've seen it or like
sometimes like rounding down to zero
is different like it's then a true zero
it's almost like a truly missing value
is different than like something that's
not entered who knows
there's a difference there it just hits
different these these zeros whether
they're like really zeros or not
so now we have ones which are a bit more
complex
uh but still useful i think so this one
here called sub small vowels
so here we get this issue where like
you have really small values
but you don't want to put in all like
the zeros
you just want to say it's really small
it's like below this number it's like
it's not zero but it's like really small
so that's what you can use what you can
do with this one sub small vowels
so
same as before it's got the data you can
focus it on columns and rows
uh there's actually a threshold value
this this tells gt what small is like
that's the definition of small in this
case
and this is a bit complex usually you
don't put like an fl statement
in your pattern so that's also another
thing we have a pattern in this case
the pattern is basically
this like
uh
curly brace x that'll be the value
basically of you know
it'll basically be the threshold
essentially this will go into there
and then you can like wrap stuff around
like literal values so basically if the
sign which means like if the values are
positive
any values which are below this
threshold will get this less than
threshold value
okay and if
you know we also have negative values
because we have small negative values
it's a weird case
it's handled separately you just put
sine and sine minus like sine negative
sign
and then the other case will be
you know
this is very strange less than the
absolute value of minus
the threshold value which is kind of
weird but
i couldn't really find a better way to
represent that
but i imagine the case is not too you
know you don't get very many cases where
you have small negative values but it's
there in case you need it
so let's take a look at this we'll play
around so we got this table here
oh let me just get rid of this let's see
it again
and i'll bring this down a bit
okay so we have some really small values
and we're getting to like bigger values
so obviously like we're going to like
target these values at the top here for
as being small
so um
the default value is 0.01
so somewhere around here we don't know
if it's going to include this or not but
we're about to find that out
um
but yeah i'll show you the beforehand
one
we can still format the number in that
column i'll make this bigger
okay so all values are formatted which
just means that
before we had this
and we don't really want that so now we
have this after formatting we have two
decimal places as default
uh we can't even see like the actual
small values here so this is just right
for replacing with like something
smaller than some threshold
so let's actually run this
and there it is so these are smaller
than that value
it doesn't seem to include it seems like
it's less than not less than and equal
to that value
um which is sometimes i think it's
actually maybe a good thing to have it
like that because like you probably want
to keep these values
and just have it less than like not
including that value
um
so that's how that works and we can
change
uh the pattern let me try that actually
we can even like not include
like this at all let's actually just run
this by itself so that is basically that
without anything around it
this is the default
right here
right there
and then later on i'll show you that you
don't have to use this but first i'm
going to show you the negative
case
so let's pretend for instance we have
the tables we have before we're gonna
make all the numbers negative
so going into gt is gonna look like this
so it's all unformatted so we're gonna
format that column first for my number
great
and now we have um
these values here
which did round i think to like positive
so it's really kind of like weird right
but we know these are negative values so
it's kind of a weird thing
so
uh let's ask you just run this this in
this case the sign is negative so it's
going to consider all like negative
small values like really close to zero
okay so remember this
yeah and now we get this sort of like
less than the absolute value of this
threshold in the minus direction
so kind of cool is the same default we
even have to change it to like minus
0.01 we it just knew by virtue of the
fact that we had
the minus sign it just handled it as as
a negative case
so here's another example uh the
threshold is much smaller i think we'll
get one value in there which is the top
value and we just replace it with a
literal string like small like this
so check it out um yeah formatting as
before
yeah we don't know how small these are
because we cut off like the actual like
digits
but
this will reveal
there you go that one's small and we can
always do this too like if you want to
just touch up it formatting you can do
decimals
three
and i believe in this case
the top yeah the one below the replace
value will still show its decimal place
and if you really don't like that you
can do uh i believe there's one called
asic big
and that's number of significant digits
you want to keep and i believe that is
very similar
oh
not quite um
it runs down some direction
uh okay so we have like we did the small
values now there's also like
this sort of like complement which is
sub large values
because you never know you might have
like these large values you don't want
all zeros and you know you may not want
to use that scientific notation which is
supposed to solve that
um but yeah we can totally do that we
can substitute large values in the table
body but something else
and it uses me the same sort of like
arguments uh
threshold for one obviously much bigger
like
one times ten to the twelve
um so big uh a large pattern is
different it's not like complex like the
other one um
you could basically just write yourself
if you want it to be less than and sine
is is there as well so very similar
let's run through some examples okay so
again i'm making my own table
there we go
um
basically 0 and a just for good measure
to have those in there just to see
that's not affected by that
and super huge values okay so i'm going
to make this bit smaller because we
looked at that
let me know step by step i'm going to
show you that
yes you can format the numbers
really big if you didn't format the
numbers
you probably don't want that
you probably don't really want this
either
but if you did
and you really didn't want the really
big values you could run this
and there you go and these values are
bigger than
like like 1 times 10 to 12.
unfortunately this is not really nicely
formatted and there's no real way of
forming this actual thing
uh which is kind of crappy uh but you
can put in your own thing
at least and i think and in the later
updates i maybe i'm gonna make it
possible
to format these itself
but at the moment it's not easy to do or
it's really tough
but it's okay because we can actually
change things we can actually say do i
have an example here yes i do okay but
let's get to the negative case because
you never know you might have large
negative numbers
uh depending on what you're doing
so those are the large negative numbers
i'm
same as before except it has
a negative sign and in this case we only
have to to do much the same thing we
just have to use sine equals
in quotes
then we have this and this automatically
changes to like less than
because
it's weird
now we're going
yeah it's gonna be less lesser of a
negative number
man this math stuff is tough for
scientific digits and now this yeah so
i'm gonna have values which are less
than this large negative value
okay
it makes sense you just have to think
about it for a second because we're in
negative land
okay
so we don't just settle with like as i
say here the default threshold value or
the default replacement pattern
in large pattern i can change it
so in this case i change the threshold
to be a bit smaller
and we're doing positives in this case
large pattern is just a word huge among
us
we're gonna run this
and then here we go
all the way down you get this thing yeah
markdown
definitely it should totally work just
to prove it it works across all these
functions let's run this again
all right yeah great
[Music]
yeah these are like uh these
substitution functions functions are
like finishing touches just in case
you know you if you need it
it's there you know you need it but if
you don't need it
don't worry about it
uh but some people need it
like like one case especially is like
the uh not the sub-zero one but the sub
small values
you may have like values which are below
a certain threshold could be like
measurement stuff like the lower
detection rate
you can have all sorts of like
specialized words depending on your your
your area of focus like your research
subject which denote that these values
are small but not zero
this is probably the most important one
but this is also important too for like
really huge values just really big
you can just say that
you